tout le monde l'a remarqué depuis le
début de l'année quand on lit les prises
de position de votre parti vous avez le
parti conservateur a dénoncé l'aspect
secret des nominations au sénat
vous avez sommé le gouvernement trudeau
de rendre publics les évaluations sur le
contrat avec l'arabie saoudite
votre chef on le mentionnait demande de
rencontrer le premier ministre pour la
préparation du budget vous êtes pour une
enquête sur les femmes autochtones
assassiné disparu d'accord avec l'idée
du retour du formulaire long qu'est ce
qui t'arrive vite
le parti conservateur de monsieur harper
n'existe plus on a tourné la page c'est
comme si tout d'un coup il y avait un
180° sur une foule dangereux qui vous
définit ses yeux à peine six mois
vous savez la politique qui évolue
toujours les choses évoluent mais ça
peut être un grand père ministre fait un
excellent travail aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans d'autres temps monsieur
trudeau disaient qu'ils avaient hâte
odette d'avoir les rênes du pays dans
les mains pour régler le problème
d'oreille badaoui a dit en campagne qui
achetaient très pas des f-35 pas
longtemps par après son ministre de la
défense a commencé à dire c'est moins
sûr vous savez les choses évoluent nous
regardons aujourd'hui les choses billes
des analyses qu'il est cocu se reprenait
mais aujourd'hui en janvier 2016 la
situation est ce qu'elle est soissons
mondiale que changer qui évolue et le
dossier des femmes autochtones nos
positions on sait qu'il ya eu énormément
d'études faut régler le problème mais
pour nous à l'époque c'était pas la face
il y aura une commission
ok c'est correct on va faire ce qu'il
faut pour que cette commission et les
mandats nécessaires on va travailler
dans ce sens là